this is the Golden Lion cheeky one of
the most powerful characters in all of
One Piece a living legend that fought on
one level with the likes of rocks Roger
GARP and sengoku and yet Shiki is a
character that even some of the most
hardcore fans don't even know is a Canon
part of the story that he's still alive
and well somewhere out here in the world
of one piece a world where now all of
his potential Rivals kaido big mom and
whitebeards have all vanished from the
playing field at exactly the same time
that he promised to carry out his big
plan to take over the world is this just
a coincidence or is there actual proof
in the story that the Golden Lion has
been secretly pulling the strings from
behind the scenes orchestrating all the
major events in one piece turns out
there is not only of shiki's
fingerprints that he left throughout the
story but as we'll see at the end also
for a friendship between GARP Roger Rox
and him in his youth let's find out why
the golden line cheeky also known as the
flying pirate is a bit of an enigma in
one piece if you've heard his name
before you probably remember Shiki as
the main antagonist of the one piece
movie strong world that came out in
December
2009 that even though is already 13
years old is still one of the best one
piece movies ever created I think the
reason for that is simple while the
events of strong worlds just like
Stampede film red or Film Z are not part
of the official one-piece canon meaning
they never officially happened as a part
of the story shiki's character has been
confirmed as Canon on multiple occasions
by Ichiro Ora the author of One Piece so
very much unlike other Powerful movie
characters like utta Admiral Cipher or
former Raja pirate Douglas bullet the
Golden Lion cheeky is confirmed to be
alive somewhere out there in the one
piece world and while the events in the
movie Never Happened his past and powers
are very real Inc including his powerful
devil fruit ability to make anything and
anyone he touches levitate and control
them at will as you've guessed this will
of course be important later on so what
do we actually know about this character
turns out quite a lot actually on top of
a number of official mentions in the
regular storyline Strong World also
released with the official chapter 0 of
one piece that not only describes most
of shiki's past but also revealed a
number of other impactful events that
have been incredibly important to the
story you want an example all right the
chapter for example reveals that Dragon
mihawk crocodile and doflamingo were all
present at Roger's execution or how
Shanks recruited usop's father yasob and
started his own pirate crew later
becoming of course a yonko shaky himself
used to be part of the legendary and
Infamous rocks pirate crew that included
the likes of big mom kaido and
Whitebeard all of who would later on
turn out to become EMP of the sea the
most powerful and influential pirates in
the world after rocks Was Defeated
during the god Valley incident and The
Rock's Pirates were disbanded Shiki
became a captain himself leading the
strongest and largest Fleet on the
planet and becoming a true pillar of the
old era he had a ton of respect for
Roger whom he had a rivalry with similar
to Whitebeard and when sheiki found out
that Roger had located one of the
ancient weapons he tried to persuade
Roger to become his right-hand man and
together take over the worlds following
the dream of his former Captain Rox when
Roger declined that offer the Battle of
Edward became shiki's Fleet had the
Roger Pirates completely surrounded when
a sudden change of weather sank half of
shiki's ships and a piece of wood got
stuck in his skull as a result the Raja
Pirates were able to escape and later
when Roger let himself be captured by
GARP to kick off the great pirate era to
find the next Joy boy Shiki who didn't
know that went to Marine Ford on his own
to stop the Marines only to find out
that unlike Ace Roger was going to be
executed in his hometown of loketown
located in the East blue yeah you heard
that right Shiki did the entire
marineford war on his own until he was
ultimately stopped and captured by Garb
and sengoku in a battle that destroyed
half the islands as a result Shiki was
then brought to imple down the Marines
underwater prison legendary for its
cruelty and escape proof layouts and yet
Shiki managed to escape here after only
two years and to this day he remains the
only person in history to ever escape
the prison on his own how well without
betting an eye he cut off his own legs
to get rid of his seastone cuffs so he
could use his ability and Escape he then
replaced his legs with his two legendary
name blades and went to see his old maid
Whitebeard for little chat telling him
about a new plan of his that would be
carry carried out in 20 years in fact
despite his quite comical and
charismatic personality all other
Legends of this era know him for a
cunning schemer and dangerously powerful
enemy and so since shiki's actions in
Strong World were not canon but his plan
to show the world hell in 20 years very
much is are there any hints out there
that Shiki could actually be active in
the one piece world right now yes there
are and Shout out once again to Mr
Bushido who gave me the idea for this
theory on my subreddits if you want to
check it out Link in the description so
remember shiki's devil fruit the ability
to let anything that he touches levitate
with full control over it turns out
there are a number of instances
throughout the story where objects and
even people levitate that are
unexplained to this day after the war at
Marine Fort and in preparation for the
time skip we see a poo a member of the
worst generation who would later on
become a part of kaido's crew floating
up into the sky similarly we see the
ship of bone [ __ ] another member of the
worst generation being sucked into a
giant object levitating over the ocean
then we have this mysterious Shrine
floating casually in the air in early
wano we see a mysterious man sharing a
cup of sake with crocus whose Japanese
attire and long golden hair very much
resemble shikis and we see kurosumi
Higurashi the old hack who helped kaido
and Orochi claim power in wano and who
wielded bunkley's devil fruit before him
change her face into that of a younger
Shiki do any of these things prove that
cheeky is abducting promising young
Pirates scheming with former Raja
Pirates and overthrowing governments or
maybe let's look at the evidence here
let's start with a pool well there is
very little that we can actually go off
of here this could be any sort of
ability or an invisible staircase but so
far shikis is the only devil fruit that
we know of that would allow such a feat
So in theory at least it would check out
now the case of Beach is a lot more
extreme he is literally levitating
against his will and sucked into this
giant object again could this be
something else absolutely could but we
also know that shiki's ship is a literal
floating island and that thing could
certainly be just that why would she
want Capone beige and the Poo out of all
people in the first place we'll get to
that in a second as for the floating
Shrine in wano but this could just be a
trick of the perspective or simply a
drawing error made by Oda only that it
is deliberately drawn a second time in
the manga clearly once again levitating
in the air and as Shiki explains to us
things that he makes levitate will keep
levitating until he stops it or is
knocked unconscious so this one would
check out as well is that enough though
to speculate that Shiki will become an
active part of the story again much less
the hidden Mastermind that has been
pulling the strings from behind the
scenes and that Oda has actively kept
hidden from us all this time for this
big reveal at least I find it
interesting that shiki's face and name
have been popping up quite a lot
recently again shiki's face appearing in
wano connecting him to the kurosumi is
one thing but sengoku revealing that he
was part of the Rocks Pirates and named
in the same sentence as kaido big mom
and Whitebeard did set off some alarm
bells for me because suddenly Shiki is
not only connected to Roger GARP and
Whitebeard because they were all in the
same era and he was a great pirate but
now he was also an active part of the
god Valley incident and yet he was on
friendly terms with Whitebeard and Roger
even after this we do know that big mom
got kaido's mythical devil fruit on God
Valley and we see the mysterious hack
who has shiki's face give Orochi another
legendary fruit this one also be from
that mythical Islands on top of that Oda
has promised the appearance of a lurking
Legend during the wano arc and while if
we're being honest no lurking Legend
actually appeared in wano I mean I guess
you could argue that Oda meant the
reveal of Roxy's ex name during the arc
however doesn't Shiki fit that
description much much better I mean he
is on the same power level as the other
yonko he is literally one of the legends
of the old era known by everyone for his
epic battles and his escape from impel
down and I think we've made it more than
clear at this point that Shiki has been
doing nothing else but lurking for the
past 20 years working on his big plan
but even if Shiki is the lurking Legend
and still is doing stuff behind the
scenes how do we know he's actually
working on something big and what would
a plan like this even look like well it
turns out we might already know just
that if there is one consistent theme
that Oda has created around the
character of Shiki throughout the years
it's that he's a schemer we have
multiple other legendary characters
commenting on exactly this love for big
plans and Maneuvers guard mentions that
Shiki is not the type of person who
could tolerate a peaceful era but at the
same time he would also not start
something big without extensive planning
and preparation beforehand when sheiky
is on whitebeard's ship after his Grand
Escape Whitebeard comments that Shiki is
surely planning something big again and
even Rayleigh is shown reacting to the
news of shiki's Escape wondering what
he's planning to do next after he's
captured by GARP and sengoku he says
that he will make the world see that
pirates are the true rulers of the Sea
and the last panel of chapter zero has
him straight out saying that he has a
20-year plan in the making another
really has made it a point recently to
show us just how much plotting and
manipulation is going on in the one
piece World on multiple levels for
example Caesar is controlling Punk
Hazard so flamingos controlling Caesar
kaido is controlling though Flamingo so
why couldn't there be another Link in
this chain I mean we do know that Shiki
has had connections to all the big
players in the world the Roger Pirates
including Shanks and buggy the other
three original yonko and through rocks
and God Valley he must probably have
known some of the most most important
and biggest secrets of one piece for
example the existence of emu by the way
subscribe if you think that cheeky would
make a better final villain than evil if
Shiki is not only an active part of the
current one-piece plot but also has been
cooking up a major plan to take over the
world what exactly is that plan well for
that we need to start connecting all the
dots that we've put on the board so far
and the picture that they paint is truly
shocking let's start in wano we have
three things connecting him to the
country Shiki is Japanese design the
floating Temple and his face being used
by kuruzumi Higurashi and the last one
tells us one thing for sure Higurashi
met and touched cheeky at least once
that sounds kind of gross now I think
about it and why would Oda just throw
him in as a random face if it didn't
mean anything I mean anything odadas
always means
something one option is that Higurashi
used to be part of the Rocks Pirates
which is a real possibility but another
one is that she was in cahoots with
cheeky and this is where things get
interesting as you will recall it was
kurosumi Higurashi and her partner who
pushed Orochi into claiming the throne
and also who invited kaido into taking
over the country the two of them are the
only swords that we have for the
kurosumi Hunts that happened after
rochi's ancestor kills the other daimyos
only is that actually true I mean take
conjuro's parents for instance they were
actors that were killed on stage after
being recognized by the audience but let
me ask you would you become an actor and
play in front of the entire country if
everyone was trying to kill you wouldn't
you much rather try to stay under the
radar or even leave the country as some
people from wano did when they founded
shimotsuki Village in the East blue so
could it not be that it was this group
of people loyal to rocks or cheeky or
whoever who killed orochi's and
kanjiro's parents to create an easy to
control puppet that could then take over
wano for them but then of course you
could ask what would Shiki get out of it
if he installed kaido and an easy to
control puppet ruler and wanna well the
one thing that he wanted right from the
start which started the Battle of Edward
with Roger Shiki wanted an ancient
weapon and as we now know there has been
one sitting and waiting right here in
wano taking out kaido getting his Pony
glyph plus the ancient weapon pluton you
probably already know that the two
people who claim to be kuruzumis
possessed two devil fruits that we
already know bartolomeo's barrier fruit
and bancles mirror fruit but what if
those two characters never actually died
what if this pair is bartolomeo and
Bunkley I mean I know this really sounds
stupid because they are two characters
that have been two of Luffy's biggest
allies and fans but have you ever
wondered why bonkure joined crocodile
for instance and at least when he's
around Luffy but crocodile was also
looking exactly for an ancient weapon in
Alabaster that was his whole mission
there and Bunkley has been associated
with imple down as well now you might
already hate me for defiling bunk craze
memory but surely there is nothing Shady
going on with Barcelo Mayo well remember
that bartolomeo burned one of shanks's
flags and claimed his Island for Luffy
an action that by the way basically
means Luffy declaring war on Shanks in
Pirate terms something the yonko has
very much noticed as we now know I mean
he's not the brightest but it's still a
very strange thing for Barlow Mayo to do
and remember a poo and his men running
into the sky well the only other ability
that could explain that except Shiki
himself would be bartolomeos slash the
old kurosumi dudes barrier power as we
have seen it used Andres Rosa a poo
became part of kaido's crew after this
strange event happened so could Shiki
have recruited him as an inside man plan
to take out kaido plan take out Shanks
using Luffy's powers and role as Joy boy
or himself what about big mom but
remember bage and his levitating
Adventure next time we see bage after
that he has married into big Mom's
family to the sister of Lola who was
supposed to marry Loki the prince of the
Giants and since big mom and the Giants
aren't exactly on speaking terms because
of a certain incident how did Loki get
the opportunity to fall in love with
Lola in the first place again we have a
rival big mom a former rocks pirate a
road ponig live and Al buff an island
heavily associated with the last missing
ancient weapon Uranus I made a whole
video on that by the way in case you're
interested but now big mom has also
disappeared from the playing fields what
about Whitebeard well he got infiltrated
and manipulated to buy blackbeards and
admittedly while there isn't anything
that proves shiki's involvement here
both of them are connected through rocks
with Shiki being the only one who openly
shared his Captain's dream of world
domination and we have of course karibu
a character who's with the straw hats
right now who knows the location of not
just one but two ancient weapons and who
wants to report these findings to some
mysterious person as soon as possible
admittedly the fact that Shiki has
already been revealed as the major
villain of a non-canon film makes his
reappearance more unlikely than if he
had just been name dropped however it
also gave Oda the chance to implement
and introduce him as a character without
messing up his entire storyline I mean
Oda actually came out and said openly
that he wanted to ride Shiki into the
story earlier before the film was ever
planned but felt that it would overwhelm
the audience during the alabaster Saga
where Concepts like Pony glyphs were
just being introduced for the very first
time and so I think there's a really
good chance that Odo wanted us to know
who this lurking Legend is and what he's
capable of so that his reveal as the
evil mastermind at the end of the story
hits us a lot harder than if it was just
a random new character that we've never
seen before a character that might
already have taken out three of the four
original Rivals for the one piece who
works with one of the new yonko and is
trying to start a war between the other
two all of course to finally fulfill his
dream to become the ruler of pirates and
thus in his own words the ruler of the
Seas a dream that his rival Roger
managed to fulfill 20 years before him
and I actually think that these two
characters Roger and Shiki used to be
friends as weird as it sounds something
that Shiki hints at in this panel right
here Shiki wears Japanese clothes but
wano isn't the only country in one piece
that has a Japanese theme going on in
the East blue that Shiki despises for
some reason there is an island called
The oikod Kingdom which is literally
Tokyo spelled backwards and guess what
it's where belmare found Nami and nojiko
after it was destroyed by pie Pirates
belmare who we saw in chapter 0 saying
that she'd come for Shiki if he ever
came back to the east blue again so
maybe Shiki came for nami's HomeTown for
his hometown which Oda hinted at with
nami's and shiki's relationship in
strong worlds and if Shiki is also from
the East blue well he would probably
have become friends with the group of
upcoming rookies there GARP Roger and
rocks but if you want to hear the full
story for that well you can click right
here to watch that video next